we're cracking down on sexual harassment  finally that's good you know get sexy  harassed more than women the one group  pets yeah nobody ever gets consent from  a dog  nobody people just pick it up kiss it on  the face rub its belly to that weird  creepy long pet where you grab the tail  at the end where creepy as hell with  dogs and we sound like creeps they like  it they're begging me for it yeah thank  God dogs can't talk we'd all go to jail  right just some chihuahua in a courtroom  like Percy flipped me over  then he caressed all eight of my nipples  then he slapped me on the ass repeatedly  and said you're a good girl good girl  we harassed dogs all day long and  appropriate harasses they can't talks  we'll never report you that's why  they're man's best friend  also dogs forget stuff after like two  seconds you can stick your finger up a  dog's ass be like well that was weird  frisbee  [Applause]  [Music]